or something to put the different
circles okay all right so yeah like like
you said it'll be new costume yep
circuits so ACC lower bounds with an
improved easy witness lemma
all right so start with previous results
so by my co-author Ryan Williams we have
that NX is not an ACC so just the
obvious NX fits just non-deterministic
exponential time and here's the
definition of ACC but for the purposes
of this talk it doesn't really matter
all that matters is that it's a really
annoying circuit class to prove any kind
of lower bound for and so just a general
sketch of how it was proved to you start
with some typical circuit class so ACC
is one example of that but it's the way
it was proved is very interchangeable so
start with this theorem a is that if for
all constants K satisfiability for that
circuit class on end of the case sized
circuits can be solved in two to the N
over N to the K time so just a little
bit of savings over brute-force search
then NX doesn't have polynomial size
circuits for that circuit class and to
go with that we have this theorem B
which is that ACC set on to the end of
the epsilon sized circuits is in 2 to
the N minus n to the epsilon time and so
put those together and you get a lower
bound for ACC but if you notice there's
an inefficiency here where in theorem B
we can go all the way up to to the end
of the epsilon sized circuits and we get
a savings of 2 to the end of the epsilon
as opposed to these end of the cave in
theorem a and so it'd be nice if we
could shrink that gap which is in fact
what we do there what happen what we
were able to prove is that now you can
sort like if you can solve it on to the
end of the epsilon size and get it to to
the end of the epsilon savings over
brute force then end time to to the log
to a constant so this is
quasi-polynomial time just a little bit
bigger than polynomial does not have
polynomial size C circuits well in that
circuit class so basically
with combined with the previous theorem
be that algorithm for a cc we can get an
exponential improvement in the circuit
lower bound that we previously add and
in fact you can push it a little further
this theorem a-plus-plus
that if there exists an epsilon such
that satisfiability on two to the
epsilon size is in to the end with to
the epsilon n savings over brute force
then NP doesn't have fixed polynomial
size circuits so it for any K you can't
have n to the K sized circuits and so
basically it puts the bottleneck on this
approach on the other side so now we
have to get better algorithms in order
to get em ki lower bounds and so just to
summarize what these new results give is
that the better your improvement over a
brute-force search the better of the
circuit lower bound you can get so you
can get a circuit lower bound for a
smaller complexity class so now to get
more into theorem a now like the proof
of it just here it is stated again so
the idea for the proof is if we assume
that we have polynomial size circuits in
that circuit class and we have a fastest
at algorithm we can get a contradiction
in particular with the time hierarchy
for non determinism and so with this
approach like but it's good to look at
the definition of like what this end
time to the N is doing so just take any
problem in non-deterministic to to the
end time and so the way you solve that
is just this um easy definition you
given an input we compute it by guessing
some witness why that's length about two
to the N and then we check whether Y is
a witness for X in about 2 to the N time
so it's just guess and check that's
pretty much the definition so now the
approach to try put it in little o of 2
to the end time is just shrink both of
these so now we guess a slightly smaller
witness and we check that that is a
valid witness in slightly less than to
the ends
so if we can do that using these
assumptions then we get our
contradiction and so basically the way
we approach it is this first one
guessing the witness we use the first
assumption that we have polynomial size
C circuits to shrink the witness and
then we use the faster set algorithm to
verify that witness in faster than two
to the N so let's start with this part
one where you guess a witness so this
follows from the easy witness some o
which is in Publius o comments in bigger
sin in 2002 if n X has polynomial size
circuits then all n X problems have easy
witnesses which means like the
definition of that is that for any
possible verifier v and for every X in
the language there's some polynomial
size circuit D such that the truth table
of D serves as a witness for that
verifier so in other words no mic for
everything in the language and every
verifier there's some witness that
you're able to store in a small circuit
like so in a polynomial size in fact so
this Y is going to be exponential but
then you can shrink it down and so
basically to be able to guess of witness
why it's we use this easy witness lemma
to say that there is some small
polynomial size circuit that we can
guess as the witness instead of lie so
now we've got a much smaller than two to
the end
besides guess so now now we just need to
verify this new witness
and so because of the easy witness lemma
we have that easy witnesses exist for
every verifier v so if you look back at
the definition it's it would happen for
every possible verifier v for the
language so now what we can do is we can
custom choose our verifier for some NX
complete language l so that basically
checking that witness is equivalent to
solving some
about polynomial size and I'm just
bigger than linear number of inputs and
so because of that now we can actually
just use our slightly better algorithm
for satisfiability to verify the witness
in less than to the end time and so
that's just a quick overview of the
previous theorem eight so this was for
the original proof in NX fin ppalli so
now what we want to do is we want to
scale this down so what if we were to
replace NX with NP so like assume you
have end of the case size circuits for
NP then you want to show same kind of
contradiction in the time hierarchy
except maybe use n to the D for some
constant D instead of 2 to the N so it's
the same approach you try to guess the
smaller witness and you verify that
witness in lesson end of the D time
problem is that this first step no
longer works because the easy witness
lemma only it works for NX Blake so if
you assume and psn to the case size C
circuits you don't get smaller witnesses
just from the easy witness lemma so the
way around that is we are able to prove
or so here's the old easy witness lemma
for NX and we were able to prove a new
easy witness lemma is that if NP has end
of the case size circuits then all NP
problems have slightly bigger but still
fixed polynomial size witnesses so that
end of the order K cube that's still for
all of n ki you have it brings down to
that order at K cubed and so with this
new easy witness lemma that actually
just clears up the one problem we had
with the old approach and so now
everything passes through and we get
this theorem a plus plus actually works
all the way assuming this easy wing
assignment can be proven
length a little open to the B yeah like
a compressor presentation place not
pretty well why is that you're right I
guess
yeah I'm it's yeah maybe a bit
misleading that I'm saying some witness
why it's it is a new witness instead of
why it'll be that D that I mentioned the
circuit which then you can unpack to get
why but yeah it you're right yeah it's
not gonna be the same why that you had
originally because that was too big
all right so now I'll move on to the
easy witness lemma so I'll show how the
original was proven pretty um and then
why it couldn't scale down before and
then what we did in order to get it to
work so we have this easy witness Emma
if NX has polynomial size circuits then
you have polynomial size witness
circuits so basically what we want is if
time to the N is in size n decay for
some K then you have an end of the C
size witness circuit for some C and so
to prove that you assume the negation so
basically you have small circuits but
and time to the N you assume does not
have these kind of witness circuits and
we want to prove a contradiction from
that and so basically the original
approach you can say like one way to
look at it is to take a function for
which we know doesn't have size end of
the case it's so there's one in P space
for example and try to show that under
these assumptions you can construct
circuits that small and so the basic
structure of that proof is like you
start with this piece based language and
then because n expands in ppalli you can
put p space in merlin arthur and that's
from a Karp Lipton lower bound all right
PARP Lipton result and then you put then
you can de randomized this Merlin Arthur
which I'll get into in just a second and
then from there just from the assumption
and xfinty Polly again you can actually
then put it again in size n to the K and
get the contradiction so now just to
elaborate a little bit more on this
middle one which is kind of the only
interesting or the most interesting part
of this is that we have to take this
assumption that we have end of the csi's
witness circuits or I guess just to
remind you this is the definition when
you have them it's that for all
languages for all verifiers for all
inputs there exists an N to the C size
circuit
but if we don't have end of the seaside
circuits we negate that statement and so
just to break it down that means that
there exists some language in end time
to the end some verifier v and they're
just infinitely many X such that every
possible witness for Y has to have hi
circuit complexity and so it's because
before you had that there exists a Y
that has local circuit complexity some
map for all Y you have hi circuit
complexity so because of that if we give
these infinitely many bad inputs as
advice then what we can do is take this
verifier and then just guess and check a
bad Y which has high circuit complexity
by the assumption so is that clear so
basically yeah it's you take your bad
inputs as advice and so that's where
these n bits of advice come from and the
infinitely often is you take that as a
vice and then you can get a hard
function which then with that bad X you
can guess a bad Y and then actually use
that lie with high circuit complexity to
construct a pseudo-random generator that
fools and to the 2d sized circuits let's
say and then that actually allows you to
de randomized the Merlin Arthur protocol
and with non determinism you can also
then like guess Merlin's message and
then basically D randomized the circuit
from there
hopefully that was okay is there
so now now we want to scale it down to
NP so for this new easy witness Lemmo
you instead of NX we now move down to NP
and so same approach assume the negation
and try to prove the contradiction so if
we try to use the same language as
before we run into a problem that before
we had that if NX was in P poly then P
space is also in P poly so it collapses
to merlin arthur but now all we're
assuming is that NP as fixed polynomial
size circuits so we no longer have this
first step and that's where it the old
easy witness lemma broke down and so the
solution is basically used lower bounds
that have come out since then or one
approach you could do so something I'm
in oh seven prove that merlin arthur
with one bit of advice is not in size
end of the cake and then so basically
because we had merlin Arthur here
anyways we can just try to fit that in
and see if the proof works now but now
there's a new problem that this merlin
Arthur lower bound is a little bit
weaker than the previous ones so for the
piece face language we have that this
circuit lower bound works for every
possible input length and so we're able
to even if this is infinitely often we
still get like four infinitely many
input lengths we still get a
contradiction but now with this new
merlin arthur that isn't the case
anymore and so this isn't a
contradiction as it is and so because it
doesn't hold for all input lengths we
have to basically strengthen this Merlin
arthur lower bound just enough to be
able to like overlap like get a certain
number of circuits that shouldn't exist
like so basically yeah strengthen the
lower bound and push down the upper
bound until they cross and you get the
contradiction which I don't believe we
have enough time to get into that but
just yeah to conclude we have that just
even slightly faster
it's that algorithm can imply circuit
lower bounds for classes as small as NP
which before all these approaches only
worked for NX and so now we can get even
everything in between like n QP or
whatever so the better your algorithm
the better your lower bound ends up
being so just to get into some open
problems like the bottleneck on this
approach is now on the opposite side so
before we had this easy witness lemma
what's the limiting factor but now since
that scales down to NP even the ACC
result if we had a better ACC algorithm
now we could even possibly push that
lower bound even further and so now we
just need to work on if there are any
efficient circuits at algorithms we can
improve these results and then it would
also be interesting to see like if we
could extend these kind of techniques
beyond non determinism to like for
example be px or like rather than just
shrinking from NX down to NP what if we
went to other ways like x4b px can we
use some kind of approach similar to
this to prove new things and so I guess
it's fine oh yeah I think what the
dominating factor is good circuit size
it applies to rather than the run
it's a little both that like you want to
be able to work with larger circuits but
you also want to save a larger factor
over brute-force search so like if I go
I probably can't go back but like the
original result was like polynomial size
circuits with polynomial savings over
brute force and then it scales up to
like two to the end of the epsilon sized
circuits but also a two to the end of
the epsilon savings over brute force in
the algorithm so you kind of need both
in order to get the new algorithm but
something I didn't get into in this talk
was you don't even need to use it just
for generics at is like you can solve an
even weaker problem actually of circuit
approximation so like you only have to
be able to tell the difference between
like things that are unsatisfiable and
things that are satisfiable almost
everywhere so that's a much easier
problem that we believe should be able
to solve as opposed to regular
satisfiability I mean that's just any
rack randomized algorithm will solve
that and you can even add
non-determinism to your algorithm and
it's still this argument will carry
through so basically yeah the way I
showed it it seems harder than it
actually should be that you only have to
show that basically being able to tell
difference between unsaddle
like any improvement over brute-force
they'll still give you a new lower bound
and yes I've still got some time I can
cover a little bit of the Merlin Arthur
lower bound at least define this lower
bound is that for all K there exists a
language in Merlin Arthur such that for
all but finitely many input lengths
either L on inputs of length n has sir
key complexity at least K or L on inputs
of length n to the K has circuit
complexity at least n to the K squared
so rather than just saying infinitely
often you get this end of the K lower
bound you can say they're like
infinitely many of these pairs where the
lower bound has to apply to at least one
of them we're actually not just
infinitely many but almost all input
links at least one of them has to apply
so it's still not quite and almost
everywhere lower bound like it's still
weaker than this piece base one but
getting it just this often is enough to
end up proving the lower bound weekend
let's see yeah so I'll try to cover that
really quick so if we have this new
merlin arthur language we can still what
we can do is for D randomizing it's the
same approach where we try to take bad x
inputs as advice and then use a hard
witness in order to deer an demise but
now instead of fooling two to the D what
we want to do is fool n to the 2k D size
circuits so the difference is that we're
using the same input X - D randomized to
input link so you can de randomized
inputs of length n and inputs of length
n to the K so then I guess with that
like because you're now D randomizing to
input links what you have is that there
are infinitely many of these ends so
then for infinitely many and you can D
randomized both m and n to the K so you
have the this il is for infinitely many
of the
pairs of input links that you have L sub
n has an end of the case sized circuit
and L on and the K size inputs has an
end of the K squared size circuit but
this Merlin Arthur lower bound is a we
should be able to see I'm trying
you know what I meant I had to be honest
up from my house how about next but that
seems at least leave it alone I mean
it's it's curly all right right
sorry I can't remember but for VP that's
even the easy win this part makes sense
and yeah since we have a few minutes
could you say a few words about how you
pull the disable robot or they may I
it's a bit technical and I don't know if
I included those slides here I guess I
could try to sketch it it's actually
similar to the approach in the original
just ma lower bound which it'd like the
original Laura Brown broke it into two
cases which is that if P space is in P
poly and if it's not like so basically
if it's in ki poly then you get P space
equals MA and then you can get the lower
bound pretty easily and if it's not in P
poly there's a way to use the advice to
I guess use just is it a piece space
complete language to like or you use the
lower bound itself to prove it's not
inside the end of the K and so basically
this technique kind of puts those into a
single algorithm where the advice tells
you which of these cases you're in like
is there a peace base circuit of this
size that you can guess and use to just
solve a function you know to be hard by
diagonalization or if that doesn't exist
you can just try to solve it like like I
guess if it doesn't exist then you have
a lower bound on some peace base
language and you can try to use that for
that given input Li
yeah it's something that battle makes
sense with all this paper I mean why de
l'homme de Malaysian appeals in this
dimension completely complexity select
without even the simple case assertive
and access polynomial such circuits and
an x equals x I guess even this we don't
know how to move without and W
generation what is it doing burrito I
mean so there should be I mean hide my I
tried earlier disinvite yeah there
should be another poop that uses no D
randomization whatsoever yeah yeah
seemed like when I think of the
compliment easy witnesses is just
exactly something verifying a heart
function so we're not yeah but even if
you have a function function so maybe
you can just use this to somehow through
the MX yeah well guess that maqam it but
if you introduce some de Maistre and
it's not something else
we just you know give a heart function
make heart function aid
more questions comments the best ancora
again
[Applause]